herzlich willkommen zum eindeutigen
video ich dir heute zusammen mit escape
zudem sorgte bis es kennt das ist zu dem
zaun
ich habe vor einiger zeit in meiner ins
programm einige lustige fotos von mir
selbst hochgeladen die habe ich mit
einer app bearbeitet und die kamen super
gut an also mega viele leute an katja
ist die app kannst du es noch mit mehr
leuten machen und das werde ich heute
tun ich habe mit verschiedenen fotos von
youtube angezogen und werde den
schnurrbärte verpassen lassen und alles
mögliche und dann reaction ihr life to
live das xxl youtuber und stylist phase
wieder projekten auf konnten die mir
selbst erstellen das ist fast originell
wie möglich damit komme ich nicht klar
ist dass ich 2010 mache ich mache die
arbeit das heißt du musst noch mehr okay
da nicht so ein problem aber ich bin
jetzt in der verdrehen und ich würde
sagen wir gehen mit dem ersten foto das
ein foto von tanz verbot das lädt jetzt
hier gerade rein die sachen bei der
älteste es wird alles externe arbeitet
also die rechenleistung notwendig ist
und diese bearbeiten vorzunehmen kommt
von einem server also sozusagen magie
bilden da wie macht man ein foto von
transport und tat vor und trägt seit
ewigkeiten sein war das eher würde ich
sagen schauen wir als erstes mal wie sie
tanzverbot rasiert ausrasiert tanzverbot
wenn er rasiert ist nicht klar
also das ist schon echt wieder richtig
gut dieser effekt von der app ist
wirklich krank
so soll ich dazu sagen also die er ist
nicht so eine scheiße die einfach nur
bullshit machen fotos und das ist nicht
professionell
das ist echt mehr wissen und die sache
ist auch wenn wir jetzt ein bild von der
sprengung ist es keine zahlen und ich
finde auch die app ist oliver teuer weil
man muss vier euro im monat zahlen dafür
sie nutzen kasse asien oder 1 50 euro im
jahr also ja erstes tanzverbot ohne bart
sieht interessant aus wie sehr diese tat
sie jetzt mit einem vollbart aus
vielleicht kindern jonas heftiger der
vollbart sieht immer so ein bisschen
ungepflegt aus oder mega und fliegt aus
der cd direkt viel viel älter ausland
noch mal kommen nun stürmer beim
figurentheater und ich habe gemacht hat
eine glatze oder gar das so mein gott
ich habe ich habe das mit bibel
die zuwächse kann der machen also wird
in den vorteil weit also vor ihr werk an
der glatt zu tragen aber ist schon so
hat ihr seht ihr jetzt immer mal wieder
den vergleich hier und ich muss wirklich
sagen das ist nicht schlecht
das sind über das erste fehler der zu
seinen besten zeiten also mein favorit
ist definitiv bisher hatte weil ich
lasse zudem die exporte ich hätte
gedacht machte sich überschnitten
das gibt's doch schon geschlecht ändern
alltag also weder richtig dass junge das
ist das für playboy fotos oder auf der
linken seite das haben wir noch nie war
arbeitet ja das war heute das foto hätte
wirklich hätte andere personen
das mal so sagen ich weiß nicht ich
bekommen da irgendwie so eine idee von
kelly irgendwie so ein bisschen was er
zuletzt im frühjahr aber als letzter
zeit später ist so genial
alte arbeitgeber der fläche foto da
liegt wohl richtig gebäude und plätze
also sieht dann weiß echt nicht okay ich
mache meine den nächsten weiter als
welche sagen wir mal sascha gezogen also
unsympathisch und es gibt auch die
funktionen sind schon hier und man kann
ihn lächeln dass es ist also soweit
leute ihr werden jetzt sehen wie tanz
dieser nacht das ist sehr schön dass
lassen dass dieser app deshalb drei
vereins ist er wirklich so würde sei
nicht übertrieben leid wenn es jetzt
höchstpersönlich seite bin ich sauer
lesen lachen abchecken das ein bisschen
besser aber das ist bestimmt auch bei
aus wahrscheinlich eine tonne pro klasse
besser
trotzdem übertrifft warum sind menschen
die leute haben automatisch cracks
richtig geplant kriegen so hoch rot für
den kurier das eine das linke auge und
das recht bekomme ich die augen
verändern so richtig informiert schreibt
die kinder auch leute machen wie sieht
sascha in 50 jahren aus
es ist sogar täglich apps überwiesen die
studie weist seine der schülerin maker
effekt würdest du dich verändert ja ja
richtig verziehen sich so viel verändert
denke daran hoffen dass das auch nur her
sind das ausnahmsweise echt cool lautet
europa es geht auch einigermaßen fit
muss ich sagen mach mal ein lächeln ist
das für nicht bei ihm ein lächeln auf
seinen rechner
das funktioniert nicht also der wird
dann einfach ein druck den man etliches
hier oder machen aber es funktioniert
das nicht tut man verärgert auf jeden
fall war er mutig wir müssen das pony
ausprobieren war dass sie bei niemandem
gut aus ist geht auch einigermaßen fit
hält früh auf der stirn aber auch das
ist ganz schön komplexe irgendwann
scheiße aussehen als sei das ein gutes
geschäft
okay das foto von riese und bestimmt hat
jede von euch interessiert wie sieht
diese kleine seiten sein dass eine
normale habe brown ist wie sieht wie
somit komplett brown haben ausgeht nicht
film findet blau belegten brote gegen
der rote haare will könnte wie sie auf
jeden fall trocken
gerne habe das sieht auch gefahren oder
irgend so ein bisschen das ist also das
gut gemacht hast du wohl so
eingeschüchtert dass berge nächstes foto
wir nehmen
montigny montana black denen wir uns
jetzt mal weint war ich glaube zum mord
tatsächlich gut zusammenpassen oder ich
weiß nicht ich bin fast taub und elise
gut aber erfolgreich gesichts erspart
werden
mit ein bisschen gutes ihn barsch nur
gekommen war
wieder darf ist es der achtzigerjahre
plötzlich wird er ist auch übertrieben
gefühl hier manchmal echte hardware für
nachlässige sind sperren lassen das okay
jetzt mal bitte verein und das hat sich
gut gehalten der latte gescheitert okay
leute ja alle vier jahre sind gerade
rein kommen jetzt machen erstmal ein
foto von jahr zu jahr schnell aber jetzt
volles programm für jahr aber ihre
eigene schule machen den man hollywood
effekt klein und jetzt das funktioniert
jährlich können wir jahren als haare
glätten glaube ich zumindest wenn ihr
draufklicken obwohl hat vor den folgen
locken hat
das ist jetzt unsere taktiker das ist in
bad vielleicht zieht es weiterhin wenig
wilder der herbst ein 84 jahren also wir
auch wieder so ist jetzt mal was man
draus decker welcher heißt nicht mehr
findet jetzt nicht so schlecht machen
sie mal zu noch chris christie okay der
hat nämlich ein perfektes foto würde ich
wirklich sagen um die haare insofern
jackman abgesperrt passend zu seinem
pulli gute habe wie würde das aussieht
und nichts aber irgendwie ist es cool
ist so wie cool finden wir dass ich
finde es nicht so dass der effekt ist
erst mal wieder um das echt krank und
gucken wir sogar an der seite von der
kopfhaut und heftig weil nur noch 19
sieht es so aus wie justin timberlake
früher also
dj pult braune haare sind frisch bei ihm
als schwarze haare oder doch brauchen
wir das vereinbart zugleich hat es nicht
einfach ich bin ein bisschen hoch kommt
dass wir auf
das kann wirklich sagen sollte zum
abschluss verpassen wir überhaupt noch
mal im mit seinem roten hahn und sein
bart den altpeter
das ist so das ist so der der oper von
denen man so ein bisschen angst hat im
schwimmbad oder weil wir hier so saltos
macht und so hat man fragt sich was das
zeug hielt für die ich würde sagen das
was vom heutigen video wollte davon
einen zweiten dritten vierten fünften
oder auch einfach direkt den hundertsten
teil dann schreibe es in die kommentare
jeden tag im februar kommt auf einen
channel ein video abonniert was das zeug
hält beide parteien bei jana und
natürlich auch bei mir